always Ryan people don't bring anyone
love into this no more motherfucker
let's go through some special some title
specials for you retarded oh my god when
my teeth are still yellow not here are
still yellow that's a good one
write it down not personality chance no
how about retarded comic I like that
yeah how about we had some great ones
yesterday no I know that's how it goes I
just suck on it Denver come come come on
my suck or something like that
mmm come on my balls balls full of cum
yeah now that's a catchy title yeah um
let's see we had some great ones in
Jersey jokes forget it just forget this
you forget all if you forget them all
too though I know I forget them let's do
some new what are you leaning towards
come beard no what what Rob Rob Rob yeah
I like that one
sharpening the knife just Glasson just
Glasson that's a good title act I know
doesn't matter that my special my hour
is not about that like comedy titles you
want those to word and three word titles
yeah no those are the ones the those are
the best one plus it's a shout out to
all your mom out to the podcast it's a
great key art for that like the cover
and stuff is like a hold particularly
and like kind of coyly and I just
blasted stupid and but other thing it
can be stupid it's a stand-up special
yeah
supposed to be silly yeah I mean you
could call it sharpening the knife I
like that too yeah that's actually a
really good it's but you know it's
obviously a joke I mean and you could
take that seriously you like I'm
sharpening my joke let it play yeah it's
like I'm killing it yeah a bit silly
yeah but I mean jokingly sharpening the
knife is funny I think a sure on title
and I am sharpening the knife you know
metaphorically metaphor paint so you rub
rub rub
about jokes for mu soup mm-hmm
what about fuck me in my ass hey that's
a title dog cigarette fuck me man man's
favorite what about Tom cigarette and
then the title is Tom or black that's
good you get that then you get different
audience the demographics changes a
little bit yeah
how about how about 50 inches press 9
inches in prime nitrogen press 9 inches
yeah how does my asshole smell oh that's
a good title
nailed it how does my asshole smell huh
that's what the hot in there
not all Nazis are bad they would then
what about the other side guys I could
be excitable that could be a title
that's the funny tail Nazis are bad
yeah how about some neo-nazis it's nifty
Nazis or something like that like how
about this also Nazi Tom Segura silly
Nazi silly Nazi that's a pretty funny
tongue yeah yeah that's just a fun one
there do what I did say Hitler hey
Heller yeah I mean that's a whole new
you're really doing you're really happy
finding the net for the eyes using the
conversation to go with these events
breaking it down so here's what I want
to do like no no we don't get it it's
like a shadow job you don't get it just
all addresses and they're like oh it's
not really about Hitler it's about as a
girl in the video my life back you guys
are doing good how about I like that
you're doing you're doing good
well I wanted to call mine good job and
they were up they wouldn't go for that
you guys are doing good are you guys are
doing good yeah you're doing good yeah
you guys you did well Oh about this
right this Tom Segura
what's your pronoun oh good amazing
yeah I like what's your pronoun let's
see that would work better for you what
you wrote on oh yeah cuz I have
non-binary stuff money a lot of nasty
emails on exactly I don't think you're
ready for it I have no idea I'm really
good
oh man Oh tell me always Matthew - Thank
You Nancy
how about nasty as hell how about we run
into industry now running the industry
oh you like that that's good for you
yeah you like that kind of you know yeah
sassy lingo yeah that's good
we're gonna keep the motherfuckers out
so try another fuck is that RAM 99 build
that wall build that wall build that
wall there you go God there you go
that'd be the last special I ever had oh
my god could you imagine that Wow my
life yeah boy I'm telling you I actively
this is a good title that's classic
just class is a great title yeah I love
you guys Glasson write in and let us
know if you think that's a good time we
should put up a poll actually yes yes
how about my ass yeah what about it's
not a sexual or it's just like the gays
just like the gay how about it's only
smells it's only smells that's actually
really good Rianne yeah hmm I don't know
about would you marry your mom would you
marry your mom would you ever date your
mom ask them will you ever date your mom
a good title I would date my mom that's
my title I asked I asked it's just like
the gays for far not actually a
definitely good comedy title for real is
you know what I'm saying you know what
I'm saying yeah that's a good time
company title you're talking anything it
has to be a play on it though yeah like
you know I don't know what the play is
but it can't just be able talk about
morning remember that was the best one
missed I was in here and you played four
and she's like you always do the best
you make fun of blackness but we know
she goes I love your imitation yes your
imitation effect I got imitation is yes
and so disrespectful oh my god
gah I'm going over comes frog how about
ooh I got another a good one
are you ready for it yeah okay hold on
this is a I don't see it this would be
so good
fuck you guys are doing I think it's rub
rub rub rub rub rub
no I think it's just glassing are you
feel me on timeout
no is that I feel me you know tell me -
no I'm saying that's a that's a good one
funny yeah oh here it is ready yeah this
is the title comes up on your screen Tom
Segura and I am the king of in promise
or forgive my saying so the king of
improv king of improv I like that about
the king of stand-up the king of yeah
see I could be the king of combat and
there's a king to come me yeah awesome
title so it's like oh Bracken it's so
brash I'll get so much hate people like
a cup of leaving so crazy
[Music]